Lila's with us in Idaho hi Lila welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi thank you for
taking my call
sure what's up so my husband and I each
have one whole life insurance policy and
sure life policy okay well maybe rocky
answered my question
so my question is we've also taken one
out for each of our children's children
and I'm wondering if we need to cancel
them and for ourselves okay and then do
we just take out an extra term policy to
equal that amount yeah on you guys do
you have your emergency fund in place of
three to six months of expenses not yet
we are working on that how much cash
value do you have in your horrible whole
life policies well so for my husband it
is five hundred thousand no no no I said
cash value how much will you get when
you close the policies oh I don't know I
guess I didn't understand that they
worked that way okay all right if you've
got whole life life insurance at five
hundred thousand how old is he he's 37
and how long have you had it only a year
and a half we added it what are you
paying a mine it's fifty three dollars a
month that is not whole life okay
that's term okay I don't think I'd be
shocked if it is who's it with what's
the company name Ohio National that's
probably term I don't know you need to
get into it and dig into it a little bit
further and C term life insurance is
only life insurance it costs about a
nickel on the dollar
meaning that and all it does is pay if
you die that's all it does okay
it's like core insurance the only time
you get car insurance money's when you
wreck your car only you get life
insurance money on terms you die okay
and whole life life insurance is 20
times more expensive
so instead of $5 a month it's $100 a
month for the same amount of coverage
okay and that extra $95 goes into a
savings program called cash value that
sucks
horrible savings program pays about 1%
has very high fees and when you die they
don't give you the savings and you paid
extra to get it it's a horrible product
so I don't know what you've got exactly
but what you could do is go to Xandar
insurance.com and just price out term
insurance on you guys and then that'll
begin to tell you what you've got but
that sounds inexpensive for whole life
on a 37 year old to me but you can look
into it's only $600 a year now I think
you might have some expensive term as
all you've got
but anyway life insurance on children
the only thing you would need is just
enough to cover a burial if you don't
have any money and you can get that as a
term writer a child writer on your term
policy so what I would tell you there's
go to Xandar insurance calm and Shop
some insurance rates and I think you're
gonna see you can get a lot better deal
than you've got today but I'm not sure
you actually have whole life so a good
question thank you for joining us this
is the Dave Ramsey show